about you and i feel my french uk veins
and because you tube and without pathos iucn
of reason matters with the bring you into
your name is joe very director
famous young authors exhibit
[Music]
with six teams are fresh
gold today I told you about
it because some of you
asked me to do it because it's
been so long since I made a
video  in French and I want to talk
about something that I I consider very
important in understanding learning
he even admits in learning
anything it's curiosity
so you have to be curious I'm
curious about what  concerns for example
the Arabic language and culture
where the Persian language and culture
for example as I have been in the
past in other languages ​​and this
curiosity is a factor which how shall
I say which encourages us to take  if
we are not curious  will not take the
time necessary to learn a
language and even with regard to
the choice of content that we will study
if it is very important that
insofar as it is possible that we can
learn the language through
content that is interesting and that
sweet sections and objects of our
curiosity and that is why for example
and but unfortunately in the case
of Arabia and the
people do it if he loses 5 years that I am studying
now  since these ten languages ​​where
it is much more difficult to
read than in the same case of the launchers
I am forced to spend more
time with fairly simple content where
there is a lot of repetition like
the little stories that we have at
link  and sometimes it's a bit tiring
because finally when I listen to
content for the 30th time I'm not
very curious to know what's
in there but I know that a
few
things I need to improve my  understanding that it is  t
from the Arabic of the person so I
said to myself I'm going to vary I'm going to do three
days a week because we will have to
guys from February 1
our challenge challenge of 80 90 days so
I'm going to do I'm going to make an effort
special to improve my level in
these two languages ​​and I am there I chose
I decided to do this in two
languages ​​so that there is a little
variety because unfortunately the
contents for the care for one  or for
the other that I can understand
nevertheless a enough level goes therefore by varying
the two languages
that maintains my interest my curiosity
because as the neurologist said or
scientific purposes of learning
and how our brains work
he said  that the brain needs
repetition but also new things so
you always have to give the brain something
new that's curiosity
you have to feed curiosity so for
me since I'm not one
unfortunately I have trouble with it  arab
and the per  san so whereas for example
in the Slavic languages
I have very quickly in content which
was implicitly intrinsic mans
intrinsically interesting to gruissan
so there I can't do it so I
'm going to glass I'm going to do both
the time is up  both the same
with regard to grammar because
if we learn the grammar rule
and we are not curious to
know there why we are not that we
have not had experience with the
phenomenon  which is described by this rule
so we are not curious
so we have a lot of difficulty
taking this rule put and if on the
other hand we have listened and read a lot we have seen
certain structures in the language and
we begin to wonder but
why do I teach this angle it
happens like that so at this time it
is very easy today to
search with google for the verbs languages
I am leaving but lille and the declensions
in the sand and the adjectives in Persian
everything  is available  e all very quickly
and if we therefore go to look in its sites
on the internet and we are curious to
know why it is happening like that
then there we have a much better chance
of understanding the explanation
because it has a relationship with
something that we already know through
reading but unraveling and then
secondly we have more chance of being
able to remember this trail whose
curiosity is very important and we
have to feed
it we have to encourage it so that  we continue
in our efforts to master finally
mastered we master by difficulty to
improve
do you also continuously count
in the language in the language that we
are learning
that is what I had to say about the
curiosity and I'm curious
if you have any comments or
questions please
see
[Music]